Володимиру Никифоровичу вже за 70-т.
Колись він вів насичене життя:
організовувавконцерти, виступав сам.
Володимир Никифорович дає цей своєрідний концерт
у волонтерському хоспісі  неподалік міста Часів Яр.
Він мешкає тут разом ще з 17-ма старенькими.
Всі вони - товариші у біді: жили там, де нині війна.
Будинок розбомбили. Світла немає. Газу немає.
І от я опинився в будинку для інвалідів.
Організував хоспіс місцевий волонтер Євген Ткачов
разом з однодумцями.
Волонтери просто не змогли залишити цих дідусів
та бабусь у зоні обстрілів.
Дехто з них був паралізований, дехто ледь рухався.
А дехто просто сидів у підвалі, куди ніхто не приходив.
Часто не мали нормальної їжі, хоча інколи
волонтери завозили гуманітарні продукти.
З цього з’їдалася тушонка, рибні консерви,
випивався цукор просто з водою.
Було таке, що нам дзвонили і казали, що,
от, сидимо іїмо суху гречку, бо не можемо вийти
навіть з калюжі набрати воду через обстріли.
Декого з цих старих людей волонтери буквально
викопували зі смітників, на які перетворилися
їхні квартири і будинки.
Дехто взагалі все втратив і жив просто неба.
Тепер за ними доглядає колишня шкільна
вчителькаІрина Шулімова.
Часто вона слухає їхні непрості історії і підживлює
їхні мрії про те, що до них приїдуть діти та заберуть додому.
Волонтери не ризикують говорити стареньким,
що цього, мабуть, ніколи не станеться.
У більшості випадків діти просто відмовилися про них піклуватися.
Виходить, що вони просто обездолені.
А ще з війною то взагалі викинуті з човна життя.
Допливе - добре. Втопиться - ще краще.
Відправити цих людей у державний будинок
для людей похилого віку не можна.
Згідно з українським законодавством, туди беруть
лише тих, у кого немає дітей та рідних.
Державної програми щодо підтримки такої категорії
людей похилого віку теж не існує.
По суті, за межами законодавства і волонтерський хоспіс
- в українських законах ні слова про можливість
створення такого закладу.
Євген Ткачов уже неодноразово намагався
привернути увагу чиновників до проблеми існування
цих покинутих напризволяще людей похилого віку.
Треба приймати закон, щобможна було створювати
такі хоспіси або будинки сімейного типу для людей
похилого віку, які могли б відкривати активісти
за допомогою держави.
За рік волонтери придбали біля міста Часів Яр
три недорогі будинки для старих.
Їмдопомагають благодійники і міжнародні організації,
які надають гуманітарну допомогу на Донбасі.
Волонтери бачать, що місця вже не вистачає.
Адже окрім старих з "сірої зони", сюди просяться і
пенсіонери з сусідніх селищ і міст, які теж не мають
родичів, готових про них піклуватися.